let's say you're at a Kroger and you see
me then I don't return the cart to the
cart return what do you do there's
nothing I can do cuz you've already made
your choice but I will judge you
silently and my opinion of you as a
person will have forever been decided I
think it depends on where you leave the
cart no return it to the cart return the
cart return sometimes the cart returns
really far away but it doesn't matter
what if a gust of wind hits that's why
you have to put the wheels over the
little parking curb there's a difference
between leaving it behind a car just
like in the wind versus like there's no
difference you manag to obtain the C in
the first place you were able to walk
somewhere and get the cart push it all
the way around the store and then as
soon as you get out all of a sudden it's
like I can't go another step